laurence bolloré bonsoir vincent bolloré
bonsoir je serais heureux de vous avoir
tous les deux sur plateau parce que vu
que vous vous habitez nouméa et vincent
est un manager qui réussit
formidablement bien qui est très occupé
c'est très difficile on va commencer par
toi là les gens est en train de se créer
c'est extraordinaire ce qui t'arrive
parce que la voiture est ici très bien
comme j'aime le dire mais surtout il les
gens tu prends une affaire ses papiers à
cigarettes ça marche plus le papier
bible ça marchait plus que du personnel
à l'église le papier carbone ne marche
plus que les photocopieuses avec 4
francs sur achète l'entreprise familiale
tu fais 3 millions de pertes
2 millions de paires trois ans après tu
fais 100 millions de bénéfices passés
complètement extraordinaire tu es
construit et de madelin tu rachètes
l'asca qu elle sophie calle le cnpf tout
ça alors c'est un peu l'image
quand on lit dans le journal vincent
bolloré le matin yves à son bureau à 5
heures puis après il va apprendre à 8
heures le petit déjeuner avec ses
enfants et puis il a une compagnie
aérienne mais ya pas de chauffeur enfin
c'est tu vas l'admet sans fard comme ça
de plein de qualité est un héros moderne
quoi mettre cette question se pose c'est
est-ce que tu allais des défauts ah oui
beaucoup
d'abord les bretons sont tous d'études
ont promis jeudi une unité dans le
camion peut en trouver l'autre il suffit
d'aller demander aux personnes qui
travaillent quoi y en a beaucoup
ouais donc tata le premier défaut cds
peut-être laitue sûrement oui deuxième
défaut sûrement trop gentil ouais on
dirait c'est pas un défaut de vous
l'avez dit pompidou mais non c'est vrai
rien que gentil c'est finalement occupe
de tout ce que font les gens et puis
troisième défaut je crois un certain
nombre de choses et j'essaie de les
appliquer koutoukou ce même quand
l'histoire nous donne un peu tort
pendant la mythologie entreprenariale tu
as un peu remplacé bernard tapie qui est
un peu un tapis clean quoi et qu'est ce
que tu penses de papier je crois que
dans la période
le problème c'est essentiellement le
chômage chacun chaque chef d'entreprise
qui a créé eux-mêmes un ou dix ans voilà
tant mieux pour lui et tant mieux pour
ceux pour qui la crée un emploi dans un
endroit qui n'en a créés je pense qu'il
a fait aussi beaucoup pour l'entreprise
en général en importance au pays
médiatique
donc je porte son action a été très
positive
donc tu penses que le tapis d'un mec
d'un trait quand je pense qu'il a fait
beaucoup de chose de très bien et que
c'est très positif pour la france qui
l'a revalorisé il a contribué à
revaloriser côté entreprises chefs
d'entreprise et que c'est très positif
toi t'as un peu quand même c'est plus
rangée et couettes et l'enfant chéri du
cnt quand même lui il est pas trop aimé
quand même par l'e mail du cnct je sais
pas s'il est pas aimé par l'équipe du
cmtr d'abord moi je viens de rentrer au
ciel tf1 ça fait seulement six mois on
m'a demandé du concret enfants bien
aller que pourrais je trouve que ça
prouve une grande ouverture d'esprit
prendre kezman 35 ans comme ça et c'est
un endroit où il se passe beaucoup de
choses qu'un observatoire économique et
social en face à l'intérêt si riches et
les entreprises qui prennent des cours
de cuisine ou de claquettes mois cf sa
branche ça m'intéresse
alors il ya un truc moi que j'aime
beaucoup chez toi c'est que tu n'hésites
pas à s'affirmer catholique sociale joue
à fantastic sous moi je sais pas si je
suis social mais je suis catholique et
je trouve ça formidable parce que en
fait tu t'entends bien avec les
syndicats a finalement je suis au fait
tu vas pas de problème tellement avec
les syndicats non on a je crois fait une
un certain nombre de choses ensemble on
a aussi retrouvé devant une entreprise
qui avait des problèmes et ensemble on a
ramé du même côté et au même moment et
ça a été très positif et on s'est aperçu
que finalement si on était tous ensemble
dans le même bateau et que on
s'entendait bien ça allait mieux que si
on se dispute on est donc ça a été très
positif compris cela tout à fait je
crois qu'aujourd'hui la crise a fait
qu'un certain nombre de gens sont rendus
compte que le problème maintenant c'est
tu pues tellement se battre en poche aux
amateurs de l'entreprise mais plutôt
d'essayer de trouver des clients
nouveaux contre le compliment à partir
du moment où on a fait cette réalisation
tout va mieux ce que tu crois pas qu'au
delà de la légende quand même serait que
tu as acheté la sphère familiale avec 4
francs mais quand même le fait que quand
il était petit il y avait des gens comme
l'éléphant pidoux qui venait passer les
vacances ou les fêtes que vous étiez
copains et bernheim avait tellement
drôle chez 17,7 à aider quand même pas
énormément je suis né absolument avec
beaucoup de chance de naître dans une
famille unie dans une famille aisée
et puis ensuite dans la reprise des
affaires que nous avons fait avec mon
frère et l'équipe avec qui j'ai
travaillé
nous avons eu la chance de profiter de
la hausse du dollar au moment où c'est
nécessaire
la baisse d'un certain nombre de
matières premières au moment était
nécessaire mais la chance existe je ne
sais plus qui disait la chance existe
sinon comment expliquer ton succès de ce
qu'on aime pas manquer dans notre cas ça
jouer beaucoup
est ce que tu penses que ce qui se passe
en ce moment au niveau boursier c'est
grave ah oui je crois que c'est passé
très fâcheux pour ceux qui ont investi
leur argent en bourse
tu crois qu'il peut tu crois qu'il peut
y avoir un crack réel je crois qu'il y
aura en tout cas ce grand échalas je
pense que ça correspond à une
et brutale des taux d'intérêt qui font
que la plupart des gens se disent au
fond pourquoi prendre des risques en
plaçant notre argent en action ou autant
les placer dans les valeurs à revenu
fixe
je crois qu'aujourd'hui ça se présente
pas très très bien je suis confiant sur
le moyen et long terme
ta soeur quand elle était petite elle
écrivait déjà mais effectivement je
n'avais pas fait mille sons mais a pris
mais ils sont aimés pouvoir m rédiger
mes rédactions baisse une fois j'avais
toujours des bonnes notes déjà à
l'époque jusqu'à 10 mois pour le lundi
il a fallu quatre ai dit vous avez
publié déjà un premier roman chez
gallimard qui s'appelait une saison
folle en 86 ça a marché
oui ammann est celui là vous l'avez
écrit là bas nous mieux celui là je
l'écris à nouméa mais enfin elle apprend
que c'est ça vous sortez pas de la
bretagne parce que tu fais bretagne
transgresseurs et le café la bretagne
c'est un peu une partie du même et c'est
normal quand on est entre nous on parle
de promenade
mais alors c'est quoi l'histoire du
livre est un roman qui raconte deux ans
dans la vie d'une femme deux ans au
cours desquels tout annuler en même
temps chaque c'est un peu comme ça dans
la vie et les longues périodes calmes et
plus d'autres qui sont la plaie car les
aiguillages d'artisans et au début de
l'histoire on trouve marion tristounette
son mari a quitté pour une belle nana
elle travaille dans une maison d'édition
c'est là qu'elle va rencontrer grégoire
deschamps qui lui est dessinateur de
bondoukou et qui présente le manuscrit
de son premier roman
mais il sait qu'il vous arrive des
aventures comme ça votre frère ou
avaient ils pensent que ça ne m'arrive
pas ils pensent lycée passy c'est
autobiographique ou et à vous les avez
pas d n'ai pas dit s'il pouvait me dire
- non moi je crois que c'est comme les
rêves on dit qu'on fait c'est ta
biographie italie et non ce n'est pas ma
vie pour toi que tu as parfaitement que
ce soit vous qui rêvez vous mais pas
christine villemin assassiné personne
aucun suspect absent le passé mais vous
écrivez pour quoi pour vous occuper pour
donner un jet à nouméa jeu parfait je
connais pas remarqué c'est peut-être
susciter être passionnant nous mêmes
c'est pour vous occuper pour donner un
sens à ce qui vous arrive pour laisser
une trace dans l'histoire de la
littérature asie tout j'ai commencé à
écrire j'étais animé at&t pendant les
événements si tragique de 81,4 et j'ai
voulu faire quelque chose moi aussi ça a
été l'impulsion initiale puis je me suis
dit il faut que je fasse quelque chose
pour la calédonie reste mon but j'ai
commencé à écrire et il ya décrire ce
pays que les gens connaissent pas
tellement tellement ça va continuer la
série alors ce lien autrement voilà une
autre troisième roman que je ferais pas
ce pas tout nouvel hybride actuel
vanuatu et on parle aussi de la nouvelle
arrivée